is this the end for the x-files  are we calling this x-files season 11  what are you guys referring to it as the  last season Gillian Anderson has said a  few times that the show's just launched  eleventh season will be her swan song as  Dana Scully including two et and now the  show's creator Chris Carter is  responding to those comments in a reddit  AMA Carter admitted quote the idea of  doing the show without her isn't  something I've ever had to consider the  truth will be out there as long as I  think the actors want to do the show I  think it really is it wouldn't be the  same show without Mulder and Scully  I certainly wanted wouldn't want to do  it without them so sorry fans that leads  us to believe that season 11 will be the  x-files final season I'm really properly  done now - at that point I think it's  probably a good time to say  [Music]  you